what is going on the second and third
largest bank failures in U.S history
happen in a three-day period and it's
got investors regulators and Bank
customers understandably concerned there
is still a lot of information we don't
have about the collapse of Signature
Bank Silicon Valley Bank and others but
what we do know is there's plenty of
reason to have faith that the U.S
banking system will be okay
unfortunately there's also plenty of
reason to worry that some of the issues
that brought down signature and svb
could be evidence of a bigger systemic
problem I'll explain first let's talk
about the big picture risks Silicon
Valley Bank was invested in many of the
same assets as other large Banks U.S
treasuries mortgage-backed Securities
and other bonds that have seen big
declines in value over the past year
those are actually the safe assets that
the Federal Reserve requires Banks to
hold many banks are invested in things
with much higher risk profiles like
stocks leveraged loans and derivatives
those have also seen big losses and
Banks often use borrowed money to make
those investments in effort to increase
their Returns the FED lowered the
reserve requirement ratio for banks to
zero in March 2020 and is still not
raised it meaning banks that hold
billions in deposits can hold as little
as 40 million dollars in cash U.S banks
had unrealized losses of more than 600
billion dollars at the end of 2022 and
things haven't gotten much better in
markets since then if depositors start
to demand their money back lots of these
Banks could need to sell assets at a
loss to meet those demands or they might
try to raise money through stock or Bond
sales like svb did and that could lead
to more runs on more Banks but there is
some good news banks have stronger
regulations than they did before the
global financial crisis the nation's
largest banks are regularly put through
so-called stress tests by the FED to
determine whether they could withstand a
crisis and the U.S banks determined to
be systemically important have all
passed there's also a lot more money
deposited in fewer Banks now between
2010 and 2020 the number of banking
institutions dropped by almost 30
percent and the five biggest banks now
hold nearly half of all FDIC insured
deposits that's not necessarily great
for Consumer choice but it does mean
that the bigger banks are better able to
fortify themselves against short-term
panic and Market losses to stay in
business another reason to think that
this is not a wide-ranging problem is
that Silicon Valley Bank had what folks
on Wall Street called idiosyncratic
problems meaning issues that were unique
to them as its name suggests Silicon
Valley Bank did a lot of business with
Venture Capital firms startups and
others in Silicon Valley Home of the U.S
tech industry Tech investment has gotten
badder this year as investors have been
spooked by tumbling stock prices the
fed's rate hiking cycle has been
especially damaging for shares of tech
companies because many are relying on
making profits far off in the future
higher interest rates today eat into
those potential future profits and make
tech companies look less valuable plus
it costs more for Venture Capital firms
and other other investors to borrow
money to put into these companies that
are not turning a profit in many cases
so many of the firms and individuals who
had money held at svb were taking it out
rather than putting more in svb also had
invested big in Mortgage Debt much of it
coming at the top of the market and home
prices have generally lost value since
then and the bank purchased limited
market Hedges like swaps that could have
reduced their losses in the event of big
downturns like the ones we've seen so
are we in for more trouble there's no
way to know for sure but if you've got
less than two hundred fifty thousand
dollars in an FDIC insured bank account
there's no reason to take your money out
as we've seen recently that's insured by
the government and even if banks fail
depositors below the limit will be made
whole thinking too much about how you
look instead of minding your books can
get you into trouble as rapper Denzel
Curry says everybody want to be the man
I'm the brother counting money in the
backdrop
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]